who doesn't know to wear gloves even
criminals wear gloves zoom and enhance
images that's never gonna happen please
if you make CSI type programs stop doing
it I think probably a lot of what you
think about what happens crime scene is
determined by what you see on TV and all
my the reality is so much different
science of friends Forensic Sciences
zoom in right here at this spot enhance
the reflection in your eyes the
reflection of the man's face the
reflection there's a phenomenon related
to forensic science known as the CSI
effect legal professionals in particular
started getting concerned that that was
affecting real people that were serving
on juries in real cases because TV is so
immediate you're actually seeing it it
has an extremely powerful impact
[Music]
dangerous side they were concerned that
if there wasn't the type of evidence in
a case that you would see on the TV that
the jurors would think well it's a weak
case they're also concerned that the
presence of some evidence even if it was
fairly weak evidence would be seen by
jurors has been very strong evidence
because it's got the word forensics in
here and forensics on TV means you've
solved the case forensic science is
really any form of science that's
applied to the civil sometimes but
usually criminal justice systems
physical forensics is physical items
blood to the skin traces of hair fibers
that sort of thing digital forensics is
things like phone records digital
information as well which will tell you
for example when the recording was made
it's not used all the time it is still
slow there aren't always the resources
that we need and is not always
appropriate the advent of the electronic
age has changed all that but there are
still some things that we just cannot do
facial reconstruction is most of the
time fiction you can't say odds this is
the person just from from the skull this
is just so much
like chunky pits bite-mark analyzes
that's probably fiction were you able to
determine which monkey bit him the bite
marks matched those of the monkey found
at the scene
[Music]
you're comparing part of a print which
is usually quite a rubbish smudge mark
to a whole set of fingerprints and
trying to make a match 8 million people
just in central London that so many
other people can be prosecuted it turns
out his fortune can be read through his
palms
it's also worth bearing in mind forensic
evidence is circumstantial evidence
forensic science has said yes this
person is present does not necessarily
mean that that person has committed the
offense the Phantom of Heilbronn
the Phantom of Heilbronn is very
interesting case I'll simplify this
massively the police were finding DNA
traces from an unknown person at a huge
number of different crime scenes same
Aeneid across europe and panics law
enforcement and they started to think
have we got a serial killer on our hands
here
DNA can only tell you what you asked it
to tell you the data are what the data
are but what the data mean is always a
matter of judgment even if it is a
suicide now that doesn't mean it's a
suicide is I know that Detective
Constable I think there is possibly a
tendency for people to want science to
have the answers caution should be part
of the craft which is not really the
case on TV shows it is important to
establish both the certainty and the
uncertainty is forensics fact or fiction
that's this is gonna sound rude I can
kind of forgive the fast-forwarding of
how long it takes to actually do
forensics I think human beings are
hard-wired to find out what happened we
all lost secrets we all love mysteries
we all want to work it out so you have
if my odds of the beat it's both so
where science can come in and say hey
you've got that wrong let's put it right
that's a tremendous advantage and of
course we fittin coming in the first
place and going I don't get that wrong
that's even better
[Music]
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon